une entreprise québécoise le groupe RSL
est devenu la première entreprise au
Canada à produire des diamants
entièrement fabriqués en laboratoire
groupe RSL et convaincu que ces diamants
fabriqués de toutes pièces ont le
potentiel de réduire les impacts
environnementaux les impacts sociaux de
l'exploitation traditionnelle on va
faire le point ce soir avec Samuel label
il est chef des opérations de RSL merci
d'être là Monsieur label et vous n'êtes
pas venu seul si je ne m'abuse vous avez
apporté donc le diamant le premier
diamant qui a été fabriqué dans
laboratoire par votre entreprise une
première au Québec on le disait alors ce
qu'on voit en ce moment-là ça vous a
pris combien de temps entre le moment où
vous avez eu l'idée et l'aboutissement
ce qu'on va dans la petite boîte ce soir
on part environ deux ans deux ans de
recherche de développement de recherche
d'équipements de conception de
laboratoire puis après ça la grosse
partie le fun c'était de développer le
procédé la recette secrète pour arriver
à faire ça dans notre je vous demanderai
pas c'est quoi la recette secrète parce
que c'est bien secret on s'en doute bien
mais le procédé général est-ce que c'est
un concept comme certains l'ont essayé à
l'étranger avec de la chaleur de la
pression pour recréer la fabrication
naturelle si on veut ou vous procédez
d'une autre façon notre procédure en
phase vapeur assisté par placement de
grande fait qu'on a une chambre de
réaction dans laquelle on injecte
différents gaz dans le méthane puis avec
des la température puis les pressions
requises et avec la source de
micro-ondes tout ça qu'on est ensemble
ça nous crée une belle boule de
placement
les atomes de carbone du méthane ceci
puisse s'associer ensuite dans une fine
couche de diamant qu'on va avoir mis
préalablement dans le réacteur ça peut
être plusieurs fines couches là à
température le carbone
ça dépose puis ça croit ça pousse
fabriquer un diamant comme celui qu'on
voit en ce moment ça prend combien de
temps
ben ça c'est ça dépend vraiment de la
recette du procédé où est-ce qu'on veut
mais on parle de plusieurs heures
l'avantage de ça
en fait un diamant qui est minait ou qui
recueilli un diamant naturel qu'on
trouve dans l'environnement
je peux dire pas mal les trois grosses
différences première le coup pendant le
plus avantageux
la reproductivité parce que on a un
meilleur contrôle en laboratoire sur les
impuretés avec notre procédé puis
finalement le plus gros c'est vraiment
l'impact environnemental nous est basé
au Québec avec l'énergie renouvelables
qu'on a on parle de 95% de moins de gaz
à effet de serre pour le même carotte
est-ce qu'un acheteur un consommateur
peut distinguer est-ce qu'il y a une
différence entre un diamant de
laboratoire non
d'être scientifique d'avoir des outils
très spécialisés puis même là c'est très
difficile de faire la différence
vraiment au point de vue chimique
physique optique thermique c'est la même
chose
donc on disait première Québécoise
première Canadienne ça existe ailleurs
dans le monde cela dit ce procédé là il
y a déjà un marché et vous votre
objectif c'est de percer ce marché de
percer le marché québécois canadien
mondial que sont vos intérêts vos
ambitions mais c'est certain que le
marché de plus gros marché pour ses
besoins en ce moment c'est les
États-Unis l'Amérique du Nord
bien sûr en ayant la première offre
canadienne de laboratoire on pense qu'on
va avoir notre place puis ça va quand
facile de personnes marcher d'offrir ça
au Canada au Canadien localement
États-Unis puis après sur les marchés
émergents en Europe si je comprends bien
si on magazine une pierre de cette façon
là et qu'on est intéressé par des
diamants de laboratoire il y en a qui
s'offrent à nous en ce moment mais pas
d'offre canadienne d'où ceux qui sont
sur le marché la majorité ça vient Chine
des états est-ce que les clients
demandent ça spécifiquement est-ce qu'il
y a de la demande en particulier
quelqu'un qui se rend dans la joie qui
dit je veux un diamant de laboratoire de
plus en plus quand on va dans les
bijouteries ils nous l'offre il n'y a un
an mais lorsqu'il manque c'est vraiment
l'offre justement la meilleure grande
demande en 2018 on parle d'environ 1.5%
du marché
du diamant pour la joaillerie puis en
2022 ça aurait été estimé à ça à 10%.
donc la demande a vraiment croissante
est-ce que ça a le potentiel de faire
j'allais dire tomber peut-être pas mais
de bousculer le marché traditionnel du
diamant ouais c'est certain que je peux
analyse là je peux pas vraiment répondre
à cette question là mais comme je peux
vous dire c'est que la demande est très
grande qui s'intéresse à ça je crois
comprendre que les jeunes en particulier
monsieur labelle signal leur intention
qu'est-ce qui les intéresse c'est
l'aspect écologique l'aspect éthique par
exemple
ces deux aspects là puis aussi comme
vous êtes tantôt le coup quand on vient
pour magasiner et puis une nouvelle
génération quand elle vient si on parle
du mariage ils vont peut-être être plus
porter à mettre de l'argent sur
l'expérience plus que sur la bague de
fiançailles pourquoi pas acheter quelque
chose qui est plus une meilleure un
meilleur choix éco responsable puis
avoir plus d'argent pour mettre sur
l'événement de prix à peu près par
rapport à un diamant naturel est-ce
qu'on a une idée
c'est sûr le prix du diamant est basé
que ce soit naturel ou enfin laboratoire
et basé sur plusieurs facteurs donc ça
peut varier grandement on parle de la
marque la couleur puis et tout mais je
peux vous dire environ 50% de moins bon
monsieur la baisse très intéressante je
vous souhaite bonne chance pour la suite
et je vous souhaite d'en avoir plusieurs
autres comme celui-là merci beaucoup
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI